Brenden we're here to talk about
antiviral your first feature film and
it's a film I believe that you had the
idea for when you were sick didn't you
tell me about that yeah started writing
it in 2004 and I had a bad flu I was at
film school and I was sort of obsessing
over the the physical nature of my
illness and how I had something in my
body and in my cells that had come from
someone else's body and how that was
sort of a a weirdly intimate thing if
you if you think about it that way and
then I tried to think of a character who
might see disease as something intimate
and I thought maybe a celebrity obsessed
fan might want you know Angelina Jolie's
cold as a way of feeling physically
connected to her developed from there
into what I thought was an interesting
metaphor for talking about that culture
I mean did the fact that I guess your
dad David Cronenberg has obviously made
loads of movies over the years has
worked with lots of big actors that you
had that kind of sense of that world of
maybe seeing how people are around
celebrities and that kind of celebrity
obsession or culture as it were yeah for
sure I mean one of the themes in the
film is that divide between celebrities
as as cultural constructs as media
constructs and then the human beings who
were sort of unrelated to those you know
the fictional characters I guess and and
that it's not a novel observation that
the real people are different from their
public personas but I guess when you're
exposed to that personally and you know
people who who are living that that life
it's still pretty shocking somehow in a
way celebrity culture savvy obsession or
that myth of celebrities wealth isn't
something new exactly it's kind of
existed for many years but I guess what
you're saying in the film and what is
apparent in in life we live now is that
it's gone to a new extreme in a way
hasn't it
uh yeah I mean it's I think it's always
been fairly extreme you know I think it
in a sense connects to a broader human
impulse to deify people you know I think
you look at the Saints there's
people elevated to the status of gods
essentially with the same and there's
the same physical fetishism you know
finger bones the old churches claim to
have the finger bones of a particular
saint or so I think it's always it's
it's always been there but definitely I
think now the rate at which we consume
media produces celebrities very quickly
and increasingly for no reason I mean
people there are people whose jobs or
just to be famous kind of innocence and
I think that industry is getting more
and more insular and more unrelated to
to anything else it's interesting this
obviously in the film it takes it to an
asura extreme doesn't it you know you're
injecting people are getting injected
with celebrities coals and various
infections and things like you said
yourself and those you know people
eating celebrities sell steak so steaks
made out of the cells and celebrities so
obviously a little bit viewer andre royo
now i think what's the worst real life
example you think you've come across of
that excessive celebrity culture not I'm
not sure what the worst is really while
some people were reporting that my
sister dated Rob Pattinson which I
thought was really weird there's
actually a magazine I saw it in
Australia that liked photoshopped them
together and as though they were
attending a party together and there was
this weird so like I don't know if
that's the worst example but it was
weird because it was so obviously not
true and not related to anything but
it's just like you know if there's a
story there it's you know no one has it
dates to create something totally
fictional just to cause controversy it's
a little bit about the look in the style
of film as well cuz it's very
distinctive isn't it tell me about where
you got the idea to kind of to film it
in that particular kind of clean white
washed looking way well there's sort of
- I mean there's the very sterile
aspects of the film and the production
design and in the shooting and then
there the more dirty it's grimy elements
the butcher shop and the you know the
macroscopic bodily stuff so I guess it
was just
well part of the the whiteness of it I
guess was an interesting way to control
the eye of the viewer so if you have a
completely white frame in the clinics
and then you have these the celebrity
faces on the walls it lends them a
certain weight a visual weight or you
know blood pops against a white
background and so there's a blood theme
throughout the film and so the blood
ends up having the significance but also
it's that again the the divide between
the icon the inhuman the sort of
theoretical people the celebrities as
those characters and then the real
animal body that's decaying and living
and dying beneath that I wanted to
represent that in the in the design and
in the look so those two elements are
represented and then kind of collide
towards then incredible young act in the
lead role haven't you tell me about how
you found him well I mean I had I had
seen him in ax men he was in x-men first
class and I was also the kid on a bike
at the end of no country for old men but
I hadn't been thinking of him until we
started looking for actors and then I
saw a reel of work that he had done and
we all got very excited about him
because it's you know a great actor and
has that special interesting thing that
some actors have that that fascinating
screen quality and he was very nuanced
physical actor and we needed that so so
we got excited about him and then he was
reading the script and he flew to
Toronto to talk with us about it and it
came together very quickly at that point
and tell me a little bit as well about
the inspirations that you've had for
your particular style of filmmaking so
as we say your first feature this one so
who's been really having an influence on
you so far I'm not sure exactly to be
honest I know I've been influenced by a
lot of people but it's all sort of
indirect because I wasn't specifically
trying to emulate anyone
we all drink pre-production got very
excited about the film dogtooth
and and Alps is next film but I don't
think those influences really were too
visible in the final film I wanted to
ask us well where you thought the
celebrity is session that we see in
anti-viral might end eventually it's
hard to say where this culture is going
maybe will destroy civilization and then
you know people will still be famous for
various things I think I don't know if
it's inherent to to who we are I don't
think much is inherent to who we are but
I think again it's it's tied to that
religious impulse I think the desire to
kind of elevate people and to tear them
apart is something that we have
generally as a species so I don't know
what's in store for us but I imagine
will be more of that in some form and
the idea of the celebrity cell stakes as
well well how did that come to you cuz
it's so kind of gruesome in a way isn't
it right well it's based on real
technology I mean they are developing
cell cell stakes not human cell stakes
but cows all stakes and based on muscle
cells they're cultivated and so we will
probably see grown meat on the market
and within the next decade it's very
close to being I mean it exists but it's
just still too disgusting to really
market to people so it was just a small
jump to imagine human stakes that became
a good way to have them literally
consume celebrities and of course you've
got that mass outpouring of grief or
somebody who essentially nobody really
knows actually in real life in the film
don't you which we kind of see so often
in real life as well don't we is that
kind of why you took the inspiration of
that from and were you thinking of
anyone in particular yeah no I mean it's
the way some of the dialogue is lifted
almost exactly from from the news I was
researching various celebrity deaths one
of the characters is all this
partly my grandmother she really likes
is interested in royalty and and so but
yeah I think it's just it's just that
people feel very invested in these these
people who they're not they don't know
personally but they feel they have a
personal relationship with them and
that's a lot of the film it says it's
almost in some ways a one-sided love
story which I think a lot of people
experience what can we expect for you
next name random well I'm trying to
write something and hopefully I'll have
another chance to make a film but still
still in the early stages
what kind of is Rosanna or a kind of
tack that you're hoping to take with it
um I'm not specifically aiming for one
genre but I do I mean this sort of
sci-fi horror film thing that I did with
antiviral is still I find that an
interesting way to talk about certain
things so I think it might have some of
those qualities to it but I'm not
totally sure yet I'm still playing
around
you